die Schritte langsam die Minen etwas
erschöpft es ist schließlich 2:45 Uhr
solange Verhandlungen kommen auch in
Berlin nur selten vor aber dann gab es
eben doch noch eine Einigung und deshalb
in diesem Moment viel Erleichterung und
etwas Patos ich will nicht zu große
Worte ergreifen aber doch sagen dass ich
glaube dass das hier ein sehr
historischer Moment ist in dem wir hier
sitzen denn es ist angesichts einer
unbestreitbar großen Herausforderung
wegen sehr groß Zahlen im Hinblick auf
fluchtmigration und irregulere Migration
es gelingt dass alle Ebenen dieses
Staates eng zusammenarbeiten auch die
unionsseite der Ministerpräsidenten ist
am frühen Morgen eigentlich ganz
zufrieden zwischendurch sah es offenbar
sogar nach scheitern aus dann klappt es
doch mit
Einigungen ich bin der festen
Überzeugung dass wir einen ich betone
das Schritt in die richtige Richtung
heute gemacht haben ähm klar ist aber
auch dass ein Weg aus sehr vielen
Schritten äh besteht und äh natürlich
noch weitere Schritte folgen müssen
schon die Vorgespräche der
Ministerpräsidenten dauerten Stunden
länger als gedacht weil die Unionsländer
neue Forderungen präsentierten dabei
schienen sie so einig besonders bei der
Forderung nach mehr Geld vom Bund das
bekommen sie nun auch pro asylbberber
gibt es 7500 € sowie eine
Abschlagszahlung von 1,75 Milliarden
insgesamt sind das für Länder und
Kommunen rund 3ieinhalb Milliarden Euro
weit mehr als der Bund ursprünglich
wollte der Übergang zu einem atmenden
System mit den 7500 als Pauschale pro
Kopf ist einer der mir sehr gefällt der
aber vielleicht die Hoffnung begründet
dass wir solche Diskussionen wo Fragen
der Finanzen eine Rolle spielen in der
bundländer kommmunalen Beziehung nicht
mehr so intensiv haben werden ich
wünsche mir sehr äh der dass das was
heute gelungen ist gemeinsam mit der
Bundesregierung ergänzt wird und dann
eben auch komettiert wird durch eine
Verständigung hier in Berlin zwischen
Bundesregierung und Union noch die Union
deren Ministerpräsidenten in der Nacht
noch relativ zufrieden schien ist es am
Morgen schon nicht mehr ganz so die
Einordnung als historisch Teil ich
ausdrücklich nicht das Entscheidende ist
die Zahlen müssen runter und ob die
tatsächlich runtergehen mit diesen Maß
da mache ich ein großes Fragezeichen
dahinter das werden wir sehen zumindest
bei ihrem wichtigsten Punkt haben Länder
und Kommunen gestern einen Erfolg
verbucht sie bekommen tatsächlich
deutlich mehr Geld und Unterstützung für
die geflüchteten
über die Ergebnisse des BUND
ländergipfels sprechen wir mit dem FDP
Fraktionsvorsitzenden Christian dür
schönen guten Tag ich grüße sie guten
Tag ein konkretes Ergebnis ist die
Länder bekommen 7500 € pro geflüchteten
pro Jahr vom Bund ursprünglich sollten
ist nur 5000 € sein ähm der FDP
Finanzminister sagt ja es ist kein Geld
da wo kommt das zusätzliche Geld jetzt
her teilweise wird Geld umgeschichtet
aber lassen Sie mich eines klar sagen
das Ziel ist ja die irreguläre Migration
nach unten zu bringen und dieser
sogenannte atmende Deckel funktioniert
ja so wenn die Zahlen nach unten gehen
dann gehen auch die Zahlungen nach unten
und das ist das gemeinsame Ziel also da
geht's ja nicht nur um Geld gestern
Nacht sondern es ging vor allen Dingen
darum dass man sich einig ist die
irreguläre Migration nach Deutschland
die muss weniger werden und da sind
andere Beschlüsse ganz entscheidend
Kürzung bei Sozialleistung Einführung
von Bezahlkarten und die Durchführung
von Verfahren in Drittstaaten lassen uns
ganz kurz noch mal beim Geld bleiben es
ist ja aber trotzdem so dass wir jetzt
erstmal diesen Betrag haben und deswegen
doch noch mal die Frage wo soll das Geld
herkommen das lässt sich im
Bundeshaushalt darstellen sicherlich
aber noch mal da werden teilweise auch
Gelder verrechnet es geht jetzt darum
die ich bleibe dabei die irreguläre
Migration nach unten zu bringen und das
ist das gemeinsame Ziel denn was nicht
helfen würde wäre zu sagen und die
Länder hatten ja weit über 10 000 €
ursprünglich gefordert was nicht helfen
würde das will ich klar sagen ist dass
der Bund einfach mehr Geld gibt und die
Zahlen bleiben hoch auch damit ist den
Kommunen wahrheitlich geholfen denn die
sind überlastet weil zu viele irreguläre
Migranten nach Deutschland derzeit
kommen die Bezahlkarte als ein Beispiel
haben sie schon angesprochen damit soll
sozusagen verhindert werden dass
geflüchtete Bargeld nach Hause
überweisen können bisher sind aber alle
Versuche so eine Bezahlkarte einzuführen
eher gescheitert ob an den Geschäften
oder daran dass es sehr viel
Verwaltungsaufwand war ähm was macht sie
jetzt so optimistisch dass es jetzt
klappen wird es ist bisher
offengestanden nur diskutiert worden nie
eingeführt worden zwei Städte gehen
jetzt in Deutschland voran aber andere
Länder machen schon Versuche mit der
Bezahlkarte es gab Überlegung
beispielsweise von Markus söderon hat
sie wieder eingestellt das habe ich
immer kritisiert also diese Bezahlkarten
sind ja kein kompliziertes neues System
im Gegenteil es werden quasi die
Terminals benutzt die heute schon längst
in Geschäften sind auch wir zahlen ja
alle digital mittlerweile sehr oft und
das ist die Idee dahinter
Bargeldauszahlung die ein pullfaktor
sind deseswegen Menschen gerade sich
nach Deutschland durchschleusen lassen
teilweise das wird eingestellt und wir
ersetzen es durch das bezahlkartensystem
mit deren dann kein Bargeld mehr
abgehoben werden kann sondern Dinge des
täglichen Bedarfs erworben werden können
man kann das auch gegebenenfalls
einschränken aber es geht also den
Warenkorb einschränken möglicherweise
aber es geht darum dass eben kein
Bargeld mehr ausgezahlt wird und es
funktioniert durchaus ist sogar ich sage
unbürokratischer als die
Bargeldauszahlung da werden schcks
ausgegeen von Kommunen und müssen
administriert werden also da fällt auch
Aufwand Weg Herr sie haben jetzt eben
noch mal gesagt es sei ein pullfaktor
also ein Faktor warum sich Menschen für
Deutschland entscheiden jetzt gibt es
aber Untersuchungen dazu die sagen
Faktoren warum Menschen sich für
Deutschland entscheiden sind eher andere
nämlich ökonomische Sicherheit dass es
hier eine Demokratie gibt dass hier
schon Leute vielleicht aus der
Bevölkerungsgruppe sind dass eher das
entscheidend ist um sich dann für
Deutschland zu entscheiden ja aber diese
Faktoren haben wir auch in anderen
Ländern Dänemark beispielsweise die
haben gute Erfahrung damit auch auch
andere skandinavische Länder die
Bargeldauszahlung einzustellen doch da
widerspreche ich das ist ein pullfaktor
offensichtlich denn wir haben diese
furchtbare schleuserkriminalität übers
Mittelmeer die werden dann teilweise
gegenfinanziert durch deutsche
Sozialleistung das muss aufhören ist
übrigens auch unmenschlich im System um
das klar zu sagen aber andere Länder die
Bargeldauszahlung eingestellt haben bei
denen sind ja die Zahlen nach unten
gegangen und wir haben ja weitere
Beschlüsse gestern abend gesehen die ich
für richtig halte vorgeschlagen von
Christian lner beispielsweise auch die
Sozialleistung zu kürzen auch das ist
ein pullfaktor an verschiedenen Stellen
müssen wir drehen das tun wir jetzt und
wie schnell glauben sie werden diese
beschlossenen Maßnahmen jetzt wirken
denn sie haben es gesagt es sind ja
jetzt die Probleme in den Kommunen ja
die Erwartungshaltung ist dass die
Bundesländer das schnell umsetzen ich
hatte vor einigen Wochen gesagt bei der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz da müssen
die Bundesländer sich klar für das
bezahlkartensystem entscheiden das haben
sie getan und jetzt erwarte ich das bis
Januar Ergebnisse da sind so ist ja auch
die Verabredung aber heißt das
tatsächlich dass kurzfristig auch jetzt
durch die Maßnahmen wirklich weniger
Leute kommen also wir werden ja
beispielsweise jetzt auch durch den
Deutschen Bundestag ein
rückführungsgesetz Gesetzespaket bringen
um ein klares Signal zu senden ja wir
sind ein weltoffenes Land wir brauchen
Einwanderung in den Arbeitsmarkt aber
nicht in die sozialen Sicherungssysteme
darauf konzentrieren wir uns das sind
verschiedene Maßnahmen die wir machen
es wäre ein großer Fehler es nicht zu
tun und deswegen ist das gestern eine
neue Realpolitik in der Migration wir
konzentrieren uns auf Einwanderung in
den Arbeitsmarkt und reduzieren deutlich
die Migration in die
sozialsicherungssystem der FDP
Fraktionsvorsitzende Christian D vielen
Dank für das Gespräch ich danke Ihnen